avec l'épidémie de covile 19 plus d'une
centaine de villes applique un couvre
feu depuis la loi de 1955 permettant
d'instaurer l'état d'urgence
le recours au couvre feu reste rare en
1961 en pleine guerre d'algérie
maurice papon alors préfet de police de
paris instaure un couvre-feu
exclusivement pour les musulmans de
france 17 octobre 1961
trente mille algériens s'avance dans la
nuit au coeur de paris pour la première
fois à l'appel du fln
ils bravent le couvre-feu instauré dix
jours plus tôt pour les musulmans de
france par le préfet de police maurice
papon
la répression est sanglante trois morts
selon le bilan officiel au moins 200
victimes selon le fln
janvier 1985 des émeutes éclatent entre
pro et anti indépendance à nouméa pour
rendre possible la recherche d'une
solution d'avenir pour protéger
l'immense majorité des calédoniens qui
souhaitent vivre et travailler en paix
j'ai décidé de déclarer l'état d'urgence
une des conséquences de l'instauration
de l'état d'urgence c'est
l'établissement d'un couvre-feu et le
couvre-feu a été respectée en définitive
peu avant 11 heures une quinzaine de
véhicules stationnés sur le parking de
la baie de la moselle
suite à la mort de deux adolescents zyed
benna et bouna traoré à clichy sous bois
les banlieues s'embrase à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
la france est donc officiellement en
état d'urgence le gouvernement a décidé
de réactiver une loi de 1955 une loi qui
permette aux préfets d'instaurer le
couvre-feu
dès ce soir s'ils le souhaitent de
nombreuses villes de france
métropolitaine y ont recours blois
orléans le raincy où nice par exemple
les contrôles sont systématiques moins
de dix-huit tombes
après trois semaines de violences le
climat s'apaise mi novembre
pendant le mouvement des gilet jaune en
novembre 2018
l'île de la réunion est en proie aux
violences le préfet décide alors de
mettre en place un couvre feu
un couvre feu est désormais instauré de
21h à 6h du matin pour la moitié des
communes
il va durer cinq jours c'était le
dernier couvre-feu d'envergure en france
[Musique]